and I wanted to know my first thing was
that Mel Brooks has obviously been such
a massively influential figure in both
the film and the television space you
know going all the way back to Sid
Caesar in the 50s so what was your first
exposure to him whether it was a film a
TV show what have you it was History of
the World on VHS tape
um and then it was Blazing Saddles and
Young Frankenstein and then those three
movies kind of on a loop in my house
until I saw my first Mel Brooks movie in
the theater which was Spaceballs
um so I just grew up like he was like
definitely my first comedy influence and
um really really surreal to get to
actually work with him many many decades
later
yeah I have a probably a similar
experience to Dave although my household
was really like a Robin Hood Men in
Tights place and I think also I was a
really big fan of get smart and actually
separately even like was we did it as a
play in eighth grade and I got to play
agent 99 which was just like the height
of my community career to this day so uh
anyway he was always you know
it was always an icon in my mind yeah
Alice you were the first person I've
been asking that to everybody you were
the first person to bring up Robin Hood
Men in Tights which was that in
Spaceballs was mine so I was okay happy
to finally hear someone say that one
but I know that this started sort of as
an idea that Mel had been holding on to
and then brought Nick and Wanda on and
then brought uh I can and you on David
but how how did the rest of it sort of
come to be especially you Alice how did
you end up involved with this well I
just got an interview these guys it's a
zoom interview in the middle of the
pandemic when I was like oh my gosh I
cannot believe how lucky I am to even
have a meeting about this
but I mean I think the ambition was for
the show to be a sketch show which is
obviously different than Mel's film
um and I have done a bunch of sketch
comedy so worked on Portlandia and
documentary now and I think you should
leave and several other shows and I
think that these guys were looking for a
sketch director so I was on the list so
yeah we we targeted Alice and just
we love love her work I I think I think
you should leave as like the most
brilliant sketch show out there right
now and so
um she you know we had written this big
massive
stuff with big scope and Civil War and
Jesus and Mary and the Russian
Revolution and we wanted the Cinematic
feel and uh we knew Alice could do that
and also do just the comedy of the the
stuff in the scenes as well yeah and
this is such a sort of I guess
far-reaching for lack of a better word
show it covers so many different time
periods I know I spoke to Wanda and Ike
and they said that you know tons of
stuff ended up on on The Cutting Room
floor but uh David in terms of bringing
things together how did you guys decide
either what was going to be those sort
of big overarching ones that ended up in
multiple episodes or just what kind of
things you wanted to cover in general so
before we got the room together we knew
our we knew what our temples were going
to be and we kind of built the show
around those ideas and having these
sketches that were going to be longer
you know 30 35 page sketches we were
gonna break up and then pepper into
different episodes and put one-off
sketches in between them and then a lot
of it was in editing put in the puzzle
together how do we bounce around the
world how do we Bounce Around errors we
don't want to be confined to the 20th
century in America too many sketches in
a row or any era and then how do we
remind the audience what happened last
time we saw General Grant or last time
we saw schmuck and his wife so
um you know it was it was
it was the writing of it it was the
shooting of it and then it was a big
post
um post uh build was there anything for
either of you anything you shot Alice or
anything that was written that ended up
on The Cutting Room floor that you kind
of wish had ended up in the show I mean
you could say this but like I want an
entire episode of Just The Beatles get
backs I at one point in our editing
press I was like I want I want to see
that 21 minute version of this because
we had so much material and to me it was
just endlessly fun and funny like what a
great cast everybody brought something
to that JB's move was so funny Richard
kind of was so funny Jay Ellis sassy
beats like they were fantastic the
musical aspect of that was so fun and I
would have loved to see a full episode
of it and believe me we had the material
for it but perfect you got to make some
choices
I can't I think I mean I'm lucky I think
that we got
so much of what we wanted it wasn't I
mean because the episodes could be 22 or
26 minutes it was kind of Hulu gave us
some freedom I don't feel like we had to
cut anything we didn't cut like a decide
having to make the Beetles fit into like
a narrative thing we we got to use all
the good stuff I think and I like to
wrap up with a couple of sort of silly
questions but you know as a history nerd
myself and as someone who grew up loving
history of the World Part One if you
could go to any historical time period
or talk to any sort of historical figure
what would it be I mean I honestly this
is gonna be I would like to go to like
the era of the dinosaurs and just see
what life was like before humans like
just so curious about what the Earth was
like at that time but I don't know who I
would talk to
maybe just myself I guess probably just
like screaming as I ran away but I would
probably want to talk to like a surf and
like
England in like the year 1150 because
I'm just kind of obsessed with how her
hard life has been for human beings for
20 000 years and just I would like to
see like the the daily the daily
struggle of like
just doing the most basic things how
hard it was for people up until about 80
years ago even though neither of them
are sort of particularly desirable would
you rather go to the Rock Ridge in
Blazing Saddles or the Rock Ridge in
part two oh wow that's a funny question
well I guess I would like to go to the
Rock region for Blazing Saddles just
because I've already been to the Rock
Ridge in part two to some extent yeah
I'm gonna say Blazing Saddles too just
because it's not bad people but they're
not all Confederate soldiers which
probably are a little more disturbing to
me than uh and um uh what's a telegram
for wherever the
huge football player Cowboy awesome well
thank you guys both so much it was
lovely to meet you thanks Maggie